there's no City like a mad city so when
I did my earlier video on Gotham I'd
said it had been my hope to catch up on
season three by the time the season four
started airing that didn't happen but I
have now caught up on season three
here's the plan
so this video is gonna be kind of an
overview of my thoughts go on season
three as a whole and then starting next
week I will watch the two episodes that
I missed so far and see that one so next
week I will do a review of those first
three episodes and then after that I
will do reviews of the new episodes as
they air because honestly I'm missing
having a weekly show to get to talk to
you guys about and yeah it's gonna be
Gotham for a bit so season three of
Gotham it was pretty good I was
definitely having fun throughout most of
it there are gonna be a ton of spoilers
in this and I am gonna jump around it's
not gonna be particularly structured
thoughts but overall so it started out
really well I remember I actually
watched those first four episodes on an
airplane and I remember just watching
them thinking man I've missed this show
because right off the bat so crazy and
that's what I that's a big part of what
I love I love how nuts it is I mean it
the show is stupid it is it failed every
possible logic test there's a whole
bunch of stuff that makes no sense if
you apply real-world logic but honestly
it makes a surprising amount of comic
book logic and people who criticize the
stupidity of this show obviously don't
read a lot of comics because comics can
be equally this dumb it's just rarely
does that particular stripe of comic
book superhero idiocy make it to the
screen because the screen has to be
serious version and Gotham is not that
and that's big part of why I love it so
we got the Mad Hatter right off the bat
he was a lot of fun I enjoyed him I kind
of wish they hadn't gone the the extra
degree to have him like messing with his
younger sister that's I personally like
the Mad Hatter a little bit more when
there's a almost an innocence to his
madness where like he retreats into this
you know thing of a rhyming and
manipulating people because
he just doesn't know how to function as
opposed to it being for you know
something has devious as messing with
kids so that's not my preferred take on
the Mad Hatter that's it they didn't
overplay it too much and and it it did
make sense in terms of how his sister
was gonna work and how that all played
out the whole thing with the the text
virus was okay I didn't I didn't love it
but it worked fairly well it worked as a
decent through line as something to deal
with that said the the episode the
episode sort of immediately following
the sort of capture of of Tetch of the
Mad Hatter there were three or four
episodes that were a little bit of a
lull and the show got a bit soap opera
he and I had that feeling watching it
and it took me a little while to figure
out why I think there were a couple of
things the first was is that you know we
adult with the Mad Hatter and then we
were basically watching the dominoes
fall over several episodes and with a
more condensed cast than usual there
were a lot of characters who didn't
start showing up till later on in the
season I know I loved when they showed
up again and I think it'll probably come
back to that but there was a while there
was a stretch there where we were only
dealing with like a core focus on Lea
and Jim and Bruce and selina and Ed and
Oswald and it did start to feel a little
a little soap opera ish it was still it
was still Gotham was soap opera SH so it
was nuts and ridiculous and speaking on
the Eddas wall thing first of all I I
normally don't go in for shipping it's
not my thing because I think more often
than not it is kind of forced in and it
very often adds very little in this case
I really liked how that played out I
liked what it kind of showed about
Oswald I like how had reacted to it I
loved how it just stoked this venom
between them I loved how all that played
out it could have got it could have been
very very just uninteresting uninspired
cheesy it wasn't it was really kind of
fascinating to watch the whole thing
with the clone felt like more of a
logistical necessity than anything else
and didn't feel like it really went
anywhere that said the actor
i-i forget most of the performers names
in this so i'm not gonna mention him but
the actor who plays brews he's getting
quite good in this part first of all and
I liked that you could tell the
difference in his performance even when
the clone was looking exactly like Bruce
that he yeah he did he did almost a
Batman voice as clone Bruce which was
cool it he just went a little bit deeper
and I thought that was kind of cool I
thought that was neat and Selena's
working when when Selena got pushed out
the window and the cats came around her
I was like wow okay we're doing that all
right wish which that's those are the
kind of moments I love in Gotham every
now and then it can supply them just
like okay so that's the thing now and
just kind of roll with it I'm not sure
there's anything the show could do that
I would be like wow I never thought it
would go there occasionally can take a
twist that I wouldn't have predicted but
I'm not sure there's any level of
insanity it could bring at this point
where I'd actually be shocked
maybe if aliens showed up that might be
a step too much I think that'd be it
though so um once things go things
really kicked into high gear again once
Jerome showed up and Jerome's little
stretch of episodes I think he had to
was probably my favorite stuff and I
really like the way he's being used and
not only the way he's being used but the
fact that they are using him very
carefully when he shows up he dominates
the story as you would expect this
character to do however they don't
overuse him and that's a big key I mean
that's a big part of why he was so
memorable in the second season and
that's a big part of why he's so
memorable here he shows up sucks all the
oxygen out of the room but then leaves
before you really start to feel like
he's he's taking away from the other
characters it's just great use of the
character and a wonderfully over-the-top
performance and Jerome is terrific I
love to end this there's a moment that I
really love and it may be something that
I'm reading into possibly even more than
was intended cuz I don't know how much
credit to give these writers for being
clever considering how nuts the show is
but there was a moment that happened in
in the episode where he's got Bruce and
he's got the clown makeup on him and you
know things are just going crazy
it was a moment I loved where the Joker
you know he's he's tortured he's trying
to knock this guy into this tank of
piranhas or whatever and he says a line
to Bruce and says Gotham doesn't have
heroes and after he said that the camera
just lingered on Bruce for a while and
you could see the wheels turning and I
felt like in that moment we really truly
saw the seed of Batman or the seed of
Gotham's Batman which is that it's not
about vengeance for his parents
it's about being a counterbalance to
people like Jerome where he is inspiring
madness Bruce will have to inspire
heroism he will have to inspire hope and
that is the side of Batman that I think
is getting more lost especially in the
adaptations these days which are very
big on the grimness and the grittiness
and less with him as a symbol of hope as
a beacon of hope
I mean Christopher Nolan's trilogy
talked about that a little bit in
practice it didn't really show that as
much it didn't really back it up and I
think this that moment might have been
intentional because later on when Bruce
gets kind of his whole brainwashed thing
is basically showing but you look you
shut off your emotions and your pain and
everything else you lose your connection
to people and it kind of seems to be
really really this idea of he's not
being driven by dark rage he has that
but what he's what is driving him is a
need to bring hope and a need to help
and that is a nice shift from the
version of Batman we're getting more
often than not these days so I really
like that like I said Bruce is working
pretty well for me I'll just mention
Alfred because he was kind of what
snapped Bruce out of it I love Sean
Pertwee I think he's terrific in this
park he might even be my favorite Alfred
that being said they are kind of he's
kind of coming down with wharf syndrome
a little bit which is that it's been
established that he's a decent fighter
he can look after himself but he he gets
knocked out a lot he keeps getting
thrown around to establish that somebody
else is a bigger badder threat which is
what happened to Worf all the time on
Star Trek The Next Generation so he's
from that a little bit it's not too bad
though coming back to the virus the
whole thing with Captain Barnes was fine
that wasn't that was a realm of cheesy
where maybe they pushed a little too far
I could roll it pretty much until he was
in the executioner to thing and he had
like the black across the eyes that was
like that's even for this show that's
that's kind of goofy but you know it
worked it worked well enough and what
things really started picking up at the
tail end when basically everybody came
back fish came back Mr Freeze came back
Firefly came back and it made me realize
that the log that I mentioned before I
was missing the Freak so it was really
great to have them back I mentioned just
a love triangle between Oswald and Edie
I was interesting to me to watch it he
became slightly less interesting once he
actually put the the suit on and
demanded to be called the Riddler I'm
not sure why it wasn't a huge drop-off
it was like going from here to here but
it I found it was slightly more
interesting when he wasn't actually
using the name I'm not entirely sure why
and Oswald seemed slightly more whiny
this season I mean he can be that way
anyway I think and summed him up very
well when he called him a child throwing
a tantrum and that's always been true he
seemed a little whiner this season then
is normal but given how emotionally
driven a lot of his motivations we're
that makes sense I'm just hoping that
they can maybe ease off that a little
bit I'm when I did my previous video I
mentioned Barbara I love Barbara which
is crazy cuz I hated her season one I
thought she was the worst thing and then
she went crazy she became more
interesting then she hooked up with the
villains she became more fun
then she started to try and run the city
which was ridiculous and awesome and I
was really sorry to see her get killed
off in the way that she was but at the
same time it felt right because with the
escalation they'd had with her from
normal to kill her to you know working
your way into the crime world to trying
to run it I don't know where else you
could go with her after that and it
probably
better to bow her out rather than keep
the wheel spinning now that now I I'm
talking about her death as if I expect
it to be permanent and I kind of do
it's not impossible for that Mina at
this point the show is established
anybody can come back so she may still
come back but there was something about
that moment that felt more final
obviously butch we're gonna get back in
some formed we dropped the name Cyrus
gold solid and Grundy we're getting that
that'll be fun
and I fully I fully expect a head to
come back I mean what they're just gonna
leave him in a block of ice forever no I
don't think so so uh a number of the
deaths felt very much like this is just
forgive the phrase this is just us
putting them on ice for a little bit
they'll probably be back I think fish is
probably dead for good this time and
that's about that's about the one depth
that felt a little bit anticlimactic
because as much as I love Barbara and
I'm kind of sad to see her go I it felt
right it felt like the right time in the
right circumstances fish it felt a
little anticlimactic because they bring
her back again she doesn't do much and
then she just gets stabbed by someone
who didn't really mean to stab her and
it was a little like oh you brought her
back just to do that okay and I suppose
talking other villains the court of owls
is all right it's not awful it's not the
worst thing ever it certainly I mean in
terms of like big mysterious motivations
it beats the heck out of a hand over on
the Marvel Netflix shows but it's still
not great and suffers from the same
problem most secret society bill and
suffer from which is that in trying to
find the balance between establishing
them as threats but keeping the
mysterious generally they just become
uninteresting because you don't know
enough about them to really get invested
in the stakes of what it means to deal
with them yet at the same time you're
watching what they do and it oftentimes
it just seems really small potatoes they
talk bigger than they do often and then
even when they act bigger turns out bull
there's someone else behind them well
couldn't we just have jumped to Ra's al
Ghul did we need the the middle the
middle step with the court of owls
I don't know Oh Hugo Strange coming back
was another
one thing I love BD Wong in that party
his perfect balance between sinister and
weaselly like when he thinks he's in
control he's very mmm and he is I you
scared but then the instant he realizes
he's not in control he's like by now yes
I love that that's that's terrific
um Ra's al Ghul don't really have a
thought on him yet he just kind of shows
up he hasn't done much this so they've
established that he's there he hasn't
done enough that I have an opinion on
him I'm glad that the court it seems to
now be done and gone cuz as I said while
the court didn't detract heavily it also
didn't add a heck of a lot it certainly
their whole storyline was was nowhere
near what I was interested in I mean
anytime they got a focus when it cut
back to say Oswald and Edie or you know
the the army of freaks or Selina and
Bruce or anything anything that wasn't
the court I'd be gone okay and again I
wasn't bored during the court of owls
stuff but it was usually the least
interesting part of any given episode
that that storyline was moving forward
in I think that about does it
overall season three started strong had
a little dip got better again and well
had a nice spike when Jerome showed up
and then got better again for the home
stretch given how long these seasons are
20-plus episodes that's that's pretty
good it's almost impossible to stay at a
consistently high level for 20-plus
episodes in the season we're just a big
part of why I've gravitated more towards
shorter season shows like Doctor Who
Game of Thrones Westworld it set her up
I mean those can have their walls too
but it's it's almost a given that you're
gonna get a stretch of two or three new
episodes on on a twenty something you
know episodes show so for this to be
going as strong as it was and to have as
many high points as it did this was a
pretty good season I think I'd like
season two a little bit better although
I may need to re-watch season two
because that might have more to do with
realizing just how crazy it was gonna be
in the excitement I had from that
whereas this season is just sort of more
living in that craziness that's already
been established but ya know it's
I have so much fun with the show all the
cast is good um I the I supposed to last
thing I didn't talk about Lee and and
James they're fine
they're okay they were better than the
court of owls I here's what I did like I
did like that they really pushed that
relationship and I really push Lee to
the edge and ma much like Barbara she
became more interesting the more damaged
they made her and as I say that it
skeeves me a little bit like but and
normally it would normally the sword of
oh we can't have a normal character
except in the world of Gotham you really
kind of can't have a normal character
that's not what this world is so I'm a
little bit more okay with that but I did
find it interesting just how far they
were willing to push her and it gave
Morena Baccarin more a chance to
actually do something more than just be
lovely and supportive which she does
well but it was nice to see her cut
loose a little bit even though I think
they might have banked too much on my
investment in that relationship it again
it didn't break anything so there were
some high points there were some points
there really was nothing that made me go
me throughout this season so by my
measure that's it was a fun season of
television so those are my thoughts on
Gotham season 3 when I come back next
week I will talk about the first three
episodes of Gotham season 4 and then
I'll just do videos on new episodes as
they air so what were your thoughts on
season 3 of Gotham whatever they are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast feed available
on iTunes and stitcher I'm also one half
of the punch like a girl podcast which
will be premiering on the fire and water
network later in October so until next
time this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]